atheria m-- and it's concepts
atheria simply put while bitcoin is
defined as digital money aetherium is a
decentralized platform that runs the
smart contracts exactly the way they are
programmed without any down time fraud
and third party interference and also
has its own cryptocurrency called ether
aetherium aims to enable innovations in
three key areas currency assurance
through ether which serves as in the
innate currency for the etherion
blockchain
decentralized autonomous organization
smart contracts features of aetherium
the first feature of aetherium is that
it is secure because it is almost
impossible to tamper with the
transactions in the block or to add any
fraudulent blocks in the network the
second feature of etherium is its
community following etherium has
attracted a lot of attention from people
all over the world the third feature of
etherium is its corporate friendly
structure the platform is being
leveraged by a number of corporates to
test and build various applications the
fourth feature that we will take a look
at is the possibility of creating new
assets on a theory and blockchain that
can be used as currency a representation
of an asset a virtual share a proof of
membership or anything at all the next
feature is the ability of aetherium to
process the transactions fast while
Bitcoin requires a block time of 10
minutes in aetherium is only a few
seconds the last feature that we will
discuss is the fact that aetherium is
uncensored assyrians open source network
allows complete transparency to view
every transaction alright that's all
about the features of aetherium let me
tell you about an important concept in
aetherium called gas
gasps in aetherium gas is the
fundamental block of aetherium ecosystem
that is paid for every operation
performed on the etherion blockchain it
is the crypto fuel for aetherium it can
be considered a transaction fee which
has to be paid when one party sends
either's to another party even when a
person deploys a smart contract on the
etherion blockchain a transaction fee
needs to be paid for that as well this
payment has to be made regardless of
whether the transaction succeeds or
fails gas price is expressed in ether
and the miner decides whether to refuse
the transaction process or not based on
the expected gas price one can see their
transactions fee in eighth or USD when
searching for the transaction on ether
scan dot IO when somebody refers to gas
they are either talking about gas price
or gas limit the total cost of a
transaction is the product of gas limit
and gas price the gas limit is defined
as a limit since it's the maximum amount
of units of gas one is willing to spend
on a single transaction this avoids
situations where there is an error
somewhere in the contract and you end up
spending a very high amount of gas
however the units of gas required for a
transaction are defined by the amount of
code executed on the blockchain lowering
the gas limit below the amount required
will not help much if enough gas to
cover the computational resources of the
network is not supplied with the
transaction the transaction will fail
due to an out of gas error so gas is a
commodity which is essentially a cost of
using the system like bitcoins
aetherium also has its currency which is
called ether
ether
it is an incentive that the client of
the platform pays to execute requested
operations it ensures that the
developers write error-free codes
because unnecessary codes will increase
the cost in theory 'm is a blockchain
based platform and ether is the
cryptocurrency that fuels the platform
it is commonly denoted as ATH let's have
a look at the differences between
Bitcoin and ether Bitcoin versus ether
the first difference is in the hash tag
algorithm used by these cryptocurrencies
while Bitcoin uses sha-256 to encrypt
blocks of blockchain aetherium uses
ether to encrypt blocks technically both
are one-way cryptographic hash functions
the second difference is in the use of
Bitcoin and ether as we have discussed
earlier
bitcoin is only used for financial
transactions like purchase and sale of
goods and services
however aetherium being a
turing-complete platform also supports
smart contracts and decentralized
applications the third difference is in
the price of the two crypto currencies
currently the price of BTC is
approximately thirty-five hundred US
dollars while that of eath is
approximately one hundred US dollars the
market cap of BTC is almost six times
greater than that of BTC even though
eath has a higher circulating supply the
fourth difference is in the vision
behind creation of these two crypto
currencies BTC is a currency created to
compete against the gold and flat
currencies by acting as an alternative
however eath is created as a token to
facilitate smart contract deployment and
operations
lastly the transaction speed of BTC is
much slower than eath while BTC s
transaction speed is measured in minutes
Heath is just a few seconds like
bitcoins ethers are also stored in
cryptocurrency wallets let's understand
what our wallets in aetherium
he--they reimbursable machine etherium
wallets a wallet is the place to
securely store ethers and other crypto
currencies basically a wallet stores the
means of accessing your currency using
the private key now that I have told you
about the etherium and its currency
it will only be fair that I explain EVM
now EVM aetherium virtual machine
abbreviated as EVM is an engine which
executes translation code smart
contracts are compiled into byte code
which an EVM can read and execute the
etherium virtual machine can be regarded
as a quasi Turing complete machine it
possesses its own programming language
known as the EVM byte code once the code
is written in higher level programming
languages the code can be compiled to an
EVM bytecode the etherium virtual
machine uses a set of instructions
called op codes to execute specific
tasks thus if a user triggers a
transaction of 5/8 using his desktop
wallet the wallet sends the message to
the EVM which connects with a wallet
address on the etherium network to
process the transaction and send it to
the receiver smart contracts are written
in aetherium specific programming
languages let's learn more about these
languages in theory 'm languages every
contract written for aetherium is
compiled into the EVM byte code and
deployed to aetherium blockchain for
execution theory amuses the following
languages the first language is solidity
solidity is an object-oriented
high-level language used for
implementation of smart contracts on the
etherium blockchain solidity was
influenced by Python C++ and JavaScript
it is designed to target the evm the
second language is a low-level Lisp like
language abbreviated as triple L it is
one of the original etherium smart
contract programming languages and is
similar to assembly it is meant to be a
very simple and minimalistic language
essentially serving as a tiny wrapper
over coding in EVM directly the third
language is VIPRE which is a contract
oriented programming language influenced
by Python the fourth language is serpent
which is an assembly language that
compiles to evm code that is extended
with various high level features the
next language is Mouton Mouton is
similar to C like language and supports
a dynamic full higher level language it
compiles to native etherium assembler
however Mouton is now deprecated the
last language is Julia it is an
intermediate language that can compile
to various different backends like evm
1.0 e vm 1.5 in e w ASM let me now tell
you about the accounts handled by
aetherium types of aetherium accounts
externally owned accounts AOA is an
account controlled by a private key that
has the ability to send ethers and
messages from it following are some of
the properties of an externally owned
account firstly it has an ether Balance
secondly it can send transactions
thirdly it is controlled by private keys
and fourthly it has no associated code
smart contract smart contract is a code
running on top of the blockchain
containing a set of rules for the notes
to agree upon so that they can interact
with each other as an account it has the
following properties firstly it has an
ether Balance secondly it has an
Associated code thirdly a code execution
is triggered by transactions or messages
received from other contracts and
fourthly when executed it performs
operations of arbitrary complexity some
of the advantages of smart contracts are
as follows first smart contract is the
simplest way of implementing
decentralization second it provides a
high degree of security third it
eliminates the need for a third party
fourth it provides automatic agreement
enforcement fifth it turns legal
obligations into an automated processes
and lastly it lowers the transaction
cost characteristics of smart contracts
smart contracts are self verifying and
self executing they operate autonomously
to execute the terms of the contract and
verify the transactions without the need
of a third party intervention the
elimination of third parties reduces the
cost of operations and further makes the
contracts tamper-resistant process of
smart contracts
in this slide we will understand how the
smart contract works first an optional
contract between the parties is written
as a code into the blockchain the
individuals involved are anonymous but
the contact is made through a public
ledger then a trigger event like an
expiration date or a strike price is hit
and the contract executes itself
according to the coded terms next
regulators can use the blockchain to
understand the activities in the market
while maintaining the privacy of an
individual's position let me show you
the implementation of smart contract in
a simple use case
smart contract example here we have an
example showing the purchase and sale of
a house thus once a buyer is matched
with a seller all assets are sent into
the contract the contract then
distributes the assets based on certain
predetermined conditions agreed between
both parties encoded into the smart
contract
thus the settlement is automated and the
ownership becomes undisputed due to the
transparency of blockchain AOA vs. smart
contract in this slide we will
understand the difference between an AOA
and a smart contract based on four
critical properties nonce in an
externally own account nonce represents
the number of transactions sent from the
accounts address however in a contract
account the nonce is the number of
contracts created by the account the
next property is balance this number
shows the amount of weigh owned by the
address whether the eoa or contract
account each ether is divided into 1 e +
18 w e AI the next property is code hash
it is the hash of the etherium virtual
machine code of an account this is the
code that gets executed if this address
receives a message call it is immutable
and thus it cannot be changed once the
construction is done for externally
owned accounts the code hash field is
the hash of the empty string for
contract accounts this is the code that
gets hashed and is stored as the code
hash the last property is storage root
it is a 256 bit hash of the root node of
a Merkle tree that encodes the storage
contents of the account encoded into the
tree as a mapping from the key CAC 256
bit hash of the 256 bit integer keys to
the our LP encoded 256 bit integer
values this tree encodes the hash of the
store
contents of this account and is empty by
default that was all about the etherium
concepts and accounts let's understand
the process of mining now aetherium
mining
atheria mining aetherium makes use of
proof-of-work
mechanism to ensure security the
algorithm used in aetherium is called a
thatch each time in aetherium
transaction is made a miner is
responsible for ensuring the
authenticity of information and updating
the blockchain with the transaction
let's consider an example where Bob
wants to send 1/8 to Alice now we would
take a look at the step-by-step process
that has followed in order to confirm
this transaction through mining first
bob attempts to send Alice 1/8 once
Bob's transaction is initiated it is
combined with other transactions that
have occurred in the last block the
miners will then validate the block with
a new set of instructions once validated
the miner creates a new block and is
rewarded for it thus Alice receives 1/8
after the transaction is validated
Ethier iam mining the term transaction
is used in aetherium to refer to the
signed data package that contains a
message to be sent from an AOA to
another account on the blockchain it
Darien blocks contain two things a
transaction list and a recent state of
the ledger that comprises these
transactions in the example shown on the
screen we can see a transaction where
one wallet sends 20 Eve to another
wallet the diagram shows the previous
state and the next state for the
transaction
state storage the states are assembled
into a state tree that is linked to the
account and the block the etherium
includes state routes that store the
route hash of the hash tree which
represents the system state when the
block was created now we will take a
look at the step by step process to see
how aetherium stores transactions first
a hash is generated for each transaction
then pairs are selected in a hash is
generated for each pair this way the
last remaining hash becomes the root the
block header as seen in the image on the
screen contains the previous block hash
and three Merkle trees these trees are
to maintain the state to maintain the
transactions and to maintain the
receipts also each block always refers
to its previous blocks hash etherium
ecosystem
types of aetherium tools the etherium
ecosystem consists of eight major tools
they are death ganache parody meta mask
mist wallet sperm ipfs whisper now let's
move forward and take a look at each of
these in detail death death is a
multi-purpose command-line tool that
runs an aetherium node implemented in go
it is the official Galang implementation
of the in theory and protocol and is
commonly used to interact with the
etherium network though there are
several ways to download death the
fastest one is to get it from the
etherium org website next we have
ganache
CLI ganache CLI ganache CLI is a
customizable and fast emulator for block
chain which permits making calls to
block chain without the need for running
an actual etherium node following are
some of the properties of ganache
firstly transactions are mined instantly
secondly no transaction cost thirdly
accounts can be recycled reset and
instantiated with a fixed number of
ether without the need for faucets or
mining fourthly gas price and mining
speed can be modified
fifthly a convenient GUI gives you an
overview of your test chain events
parity parity is the fastest lightest
and most secure aetherium client that
provides the core infrastructure
essentials for quick and reliable
services parity is written in rust
language it offers better reliability
code clarity and performance it is an
aetherium client that is integrated
directly into your web browser
apart from allowing the users to access
the functions of basic ether and token
wallet it also serves as an aetherium
GUI browser it provides access to a
diverse range of etherium features
including d apps meta masks
Minna mask turns google chrome into a
browser that allows the users to send
and receive transactions and also fetch
data from the blockchain it is a
browser-based wallet which can be added
as a plugin to your Chrome browser it
permits you to run aetherium D apps
directly from your browser without the
need for running a full aetherium node
meta mask accounts practically it is
unrealistic for everyone in the world to
run a node to interact with the etherium
blockchain to overcome this meta mask
hosts a number of nodes so you don't
have to a user simply needs to install a
meta mask and can automatically get
connected to the nodes
thus you can use the etherium blockchain
seamlessly let's talk mist which is
another important tool of the blockchain
ecosystem mist wallet mist wallet is the
end user interface for aetherium that is
developed for browsing and using d apps
mist is an official aetherium wallet it
was developed and distributed by the
team which is responsible for the
management of aetherium ecosystem it is
usually used by developers who want to
create deploy and use smart contracts it
is a full node wallet which means you'll
have to download the entire ethereum
blockchain onto your computer some of
the applications of mist wallet is as
follows first sending and receiving
transactions second storing ether third
creating multi signature wallets and
fourth deploying smart contracts swarm
swarm is a platform which supports
distributed storage and provides content
distribution services it acts as a
native base layer service of the
etherium web 3 stack it provides
sufficient decentralization and
redundant storage of aetherium records
to distribute blockchain data as well as
the app codes it leverages the
underlying aetherium infrastructure
through the use of contracts in ethers
to encourage cooperation among nodes the
files are split into pieces and are
stored in the nose of the network an
accounting protocol is used by peers to
keep track of these chunks delivered and
received and resulting micro payments
associated with it
i PFS
PFS is a decentralized storage system
that is not related directly to
aetherium but can be integrated with it
i PFS stores data by use of a
distributed hash table or DHT once we
know the hash we request the peer
network who has a copy of the content
located at the corresponding hash and
then we download the content from the
node who has the desired data which we
need the data transfer between the nodes
in the network uses a mechanism which is
similar to the one used in BitTorrent it
also provides a versioned file system
capable of storing files and tracking
versions over time thus it defines how
files move across a network making it a
distributed file system by combining all
of these properties ipfs is enabling a
new permanent web and augmenting the way
we use existing internet protocols like
HTTP
whisper whisper is an identity based
communication protocol 4d apps to
interact with each other D apps that
need to publish small amounts of
information to each other and have the
publication last some substantial amount
of time prefer using whisper for
instance ad app running a currency
exchange may use whisper to record an
offer to buy a currency at a pre agreed
price on the exchange platform some of
the drawbacks of whisper are as follows
it has low level API which is only
exposed to D apps and never to users
second it has low bandwidth and is not
designed for large data transfers third
it has uncertain latency and lastly it
has no reliable methods for tracing
packets
in theory em frameworks we'll look at
two types of etherium frameworks web 3j
s wimp 3j s is a set of libraries which
permit one to interact with a remote or
local aetherium node it can be done with
the use of IPC or an HTTP connection the
key connection between aetherium network
and DAP that allows you to compile
deploy and interact with smart contracts
is called web 3j s it gives us a way to
build a website or client that can talk
to the etherium blockchain
let's take an example of traditional
development when you develop a website
it talks to AP is using JSON or jQuery
to make Ajax calls a website talks to
blockchain using web 3 using JSON RPC
which is similar to making a remote
procedure call etherium comprises of a
large number of nodes which talk to each
other we use JSON RPC to make a request
to a particular node which is like an
API call thus if we want to talk to a
smart contract or read an account we do
it through web 3 e dot j s it is a
highly optimized lightweight j/s utility
for aetherium based on web dot j s in
this all the unnecessary characters are
removed from the source code and the
code is reduced to 160 kilobytes ëthere
IAM development environment the three
commonly used aetherium development
environments include remix ide truffle
and embark let's understand these
environments in a little more detail
remix ide remix ide
is a browser-based compiler and ide that
enables users to debug transactions and
build aetherium contracts with solidity
language you can simply log on to the
web-based editor
the code and compile the same to create
the bytecode in order to test your code
the next slide shows how remix looks
another popular environment is truffle
truffle truffle is a development
environment testing framework and asset
pipeline for blockchains using the
etherium virtual machine or EVM it helps
users in developing smart contracts
published to contracts and test them
then we have embark embark embark is an
environment that allows you to easily
develop and deploy decentralized
applications it performs the following
functions first automatic deployment of
contracts second keeping track of
deployed contracts third managing the
complex systems of interdependent
contracts fourth performing test-driven
deployment with contracts using
javascript fifth managing different
chains like test net private net and
live net and lastly redeploy the
contracts if any changes are done let's
talk about aetherium networks a theory
of network the basis for decentralized
consensus is the peer-to-peer network of
participating nodes which maintain and
secure the blockchain a node is defined
as a device or a program that can
communicate with the etherium blockchain
network they are also referred to as
clients they provide wallet
functionality and allow users to perform
transactions on the blockchain thus a
node serves as a machine running as an
ethereal pliant it is used to store the
data and transfer money it is formed by
combining one or more nodes in each node
contains a copy of the blockchain types
of network there are three main types of
networks the test net the main net and
the private network
in theory MD apps and daos
diem decentralized application is an
application that is used on networks
with trustless protocols to avoid a
single point of failure they run on a
peer-to-peer computer network all the
activity which takes place on an
etherium decentralized application is
cryptographically secured on the
blockchain d apps are open source which
means that everyone can verify the
contents of the software some properties
of D apps are as follows
it uses aetherium as a development
platform it uses cryptographically
encoded blocks it is not governed by a
central server and there is no master
copy of D app let's talk about the
advantages of D apps now advantages of
DM a theory MD apps have the following
advantages improved stability due to a
distributed network higher reliability
automatic credentials assigned through
smart contracts no downtime no
third-party intervention and high
security example of D apps some of the
known examples of D apps include we fund
storage kyc chain and 4g capital these
companies have developed different
applications using blockchain next we
have the DA OS Dao Dao s or
organisations designed to hold assets
and use the voting system to distribute
them they exist entirely on blockchain
and are governed by the consensus
protocols they show the potential of
blockchain to revolutionize human social
institutions called Dao s it is an
organization run by rules agreed through
a consensus process among its members
and written in a set of contracts run
via a blockchain it is an open source
software capable of modification by its
members
process of a Dao now let's take an
example and see how this works
thus consider that a country is holding
elections and wants to prevent fraud in
the voting system a Dao is created to
keep transparency in the voting this is
ensured by embedding predefined
conditions in the code people eligible
to vote are assigned voting tokens and
the voting starts every vote is
processed on the etherium blockchain and
it ensures transparency by allowing
everything to run in a decentralized way
hi there if you liked this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here